(light music)
- That time I was on the front
page of the Wall Street Journal
back in the day.
Say hi to DRock?
- [DRock] How are you?
(light music)
- [Gary] Like a
totally different person.
No.
You can film from the outside
a little bit just for B-roll.
Okay, thanks man.
We can build franchises.
When you build
franchises you sell shit.
One thing I want to make sure
that all of you know is that
I'm going to throw a lot
of things at this and
I want to support them.
Let's make sure everybody
knows that it's important.
We want to build up the
franchise. We want to tell people on
the floor telling people
like did you get the
email this morning?
The more we can build up
things the more we can have.
That's how you get
marketing success.
So keep that in
the back your mind.
We're gonna go for it all now.
It's a lot, man.
I'll talk to you more
about what I learn.
I'll see you guys
in a little bit.
Love you.
- Love you.
- Brandon, this is
what we have to focus on.
Want you to start spending
real time looking at this.
Do a competitor offer right now
with free shipping reduced price
for two bucks less than Decoy.
(light music)
Hey. What's up, brother?
Good to see you.
Are you well?
- Yeah.
- [Man] Long time.
- Yeah, man.
Looking good.
Say hello to everybody.
Kev.
- Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
- Great to see you.
Good to see you.
Couple hours.
(light music)
How long does it take,
saying until we get there?
What's that?
- [Driver] 20 minutes.
- Hey Kim, how are you?
(light music)
Cool.
Let's stop foolin' around around
we only got a few minutes.
Anything, obviously, Joey gave
me some stuff for my
meeting with (censored).
London went really well.
It looks like there's a super
opportunity for UK market.
One thing I want all of you
to hear is I believe the most
dysfunctional thing that I've
see in business since I've started
VaynerMedia is how our brands
handle global and local markets.
I have no interest in being a
version with that with London
and as a local market for
(censored) and then New York
being on the global business.
In general, I think that's going
to start happening to us over
the next decade and I think it's
a great opportunity for this
team because it's really
more you guys than those guys.
It's us as a group being the
bigger men and women and really
supporting the London office
and then their efforts in the UK
market that so I've said this to
Joe, I know not all of you work
on it but I think we start
getting more UK specific, or
Europe specific (censored)
business in '17 so
that's on my mind.
I'm excited about that.
We'll have more conversations
about that but please default
into supporting them creatively
and strategically as much
possible and always being
empathetic to how much more
important it is to them in
the beginning especially.
So keep that in mind.
That's on my mind.
That's from me,
that's kind of my stuff.
Anything from you guys?
- [Woman] Thanks for making it.
- [Gary] Of course.
Good to see you brother.
- Did you guys just get in?
- [Gary] Yeah, I just
landed from London.
- [Man 2] Gary.
- [Gary] Good to see you, man.
How are you?
- Good.
- [Woman] You know we
can't record this meeting.
- [Gary] Yes.
But I wanted to at least get this
part because I'm trying to get
you in as many
DailyVees as possible.
All right, DRock have fun.
Yeah.
And just so everybody knows
great and just so everybody
knows how I view this 'cause
there's a lot of things
that I'm passionate about.
Obviously you guys know me
you'd be stunned how much more
I believe I'm right about this
than a lot of other things that
I may seem to be
more passionate about.
That's great Kate and
team and everybody.
The punchline of all this
it's a human being thing.
Right?
The reason it doesn't work
is because the global person
Samantha and a local person
Rick aren't letting it work.
The reason it wouldn't work is
because Chris and Tim
didn't let it work.
It's just human beings and so
cool and do that but it's all
interpretation and it's
all just human beings.
I'm very confident in our
ability internally
to do our thing.
I just want everybody to know
how much I'm keeping an eye on
it and how much I'll be judging
if we even have a hiccup.
You know what I mean?
I want to guys to make a four or
five page deck on why creative
and paid working together
matters with real detail
and creative.
Make a six page deck.
This is an important deck.
I want this fast.
And you've got a deck?
I said six page deck.
Honestly, you've now set a new
standard for speed at which
I want stuff so be
prepared to deliver on that.
You better just start
making decks on spec.
Alright, I got to run.
I love you guys.
I'll talk to you soon.
Alright, bye-bye.
So what's cooking?
Hi.
- [Woman 2] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- Good.
Hey, how are you?
Wine Library baby.
Old stomping grounds.
It's the best
feeling to be here.
- [DRock] Like
riding a bike, right?
- Like riding a
mother fucking bike.
Why do you always have to curse?
(DRock laughs)
Hello.
- [Group] Hey.
- Idea.
- There's good
stuff in there too.
- I don't give a shit.
- Okay.
- I have a good idea.
Here's what, where is,
let's do it right now.
I'm gonna talk
to you through this.
Where are the orders coming in?
Every fucking order.
Show me the last
order that just came in.
The four of you, all five of you
are about to call a human being.
But here's the real
interesting thing and
while I've got all of you
Liz, George, Sam.
I don't think every one of
them has to be a sales call.
I think Liz, so
what's latest order?
I want you to email him
and I want you to tell him when
he opens the 'bello to make sure
it breathes for multiple hours.
That's it.
All right Liz, your turn.
Actually go,
actually click back out
'cause I wanna...
Great.
I want you to basically, great,
I basically want you to email
and call them
with something now.
Let's debate it.
Look at their account.
What else do they,
what else have they bought?
You know call her, call her
be like you're looking
at the account,
appreciate the order you just
placed for the Sancerre,
see that you love it.
If you need any Sancerre
recommendations or
Sauvignon blanc recommendations
or if you ever want me to notify
you and get really intriguing
Sauvignon blancs that we're
not going to promote on
the email, let me know.
Just like a thank you.
Got it?
- [Liz] Got it.
- Call her.
Be like I'm super excited that
for you to let me know, I'd love
for you to let me know what you
think once you try it and really
appreciate it and is there
anything I can ever do for you,
you've got my email.
Got it?
Do it right now.
Love it.
Oh God, I love selling stuff.
Start zoning in and being
creative on one-to-one sale.
If you're going to start looking
at customers one by one that's
the zone, when I send you shit
on social I'd love for you to
recommend in that
page 4 to page 10.
That's the beefy spot.
Be very, now you may not have a
recommendation that fits what
you need to, but be very educated
on what sitting on page 4 to 10.
Let's look at it.
Let's just keep
jamming because this is fun.
How much time do I have?
Like five minutes?
- [Sam] Like you go to page 10.
- Did you get him signed in?
Like is he getting?
Okay, cool.
Liz has it, does George
have it signed in that way?
We had labels and reviews on
every product within 12 hours.
We've been probably sitting with
this fucking bullshit Malbec for
fuckin' a month and we
have nine cases of it and
it has no prayer.
Because if it's not
reviewed here and labelled
it has no shelf talker. So...
That's it, that's what I'm
really passionate about that in
this whole world.
It also really helps if you're
grounded in the first 10 pages
to when you're doing
recommendations because you're
just going to be more
knowledgeable about
the inventory.
You know what I mean?
Done. I'll get it
done right now.
Sorry.
Sorry, Liz.
See ya.
No.
Not for me only
because I love the game.
I could be far more
successful financially
if I didn't love the
game and I loved money.
Most of my
behaviors' about the game.
I'm creating scenarios that make
me work 16 hours a day,
you know?
I can probably work 10 and
make twice the amount money.
And by the way, not probably.
I'm telling you right now I can
work 10 hours a day and make
50 to 100% more money
if I changed my behavior.
It's just not
what makes me happy.
I love the game.
I love the game like
you would not believe.
I love the game when I was
making $75,000 a year
and I was happy as a clam.
The money is
unbelievably not interesting.
Meaning I'm thrilled,
I'll take it
I'm aware that I need it to
buy the Jets and all that good
jazz but that is not
my hard wiring.
That's a byproduct of who I am.
And by the way,
by the way I think that's
actually much more
common than people realize.
You know what I mean?
Actually I do think that's the
purest form of entrepreneur.
I'm so lucky.
I'll tell you right now
this is no hesitation,
I don't need to make more.
If this was it if I'm already
unbelievably blessed, you know?
I don't need stuff.
I like flying private
to save five hours but
I'm thrilled to fly coach,
middle seat if
I can't afford it.
It's not like oh dammit.
When you come from
very humble beginnings,
you've tasted that before.
It's not scary.
And by the way, I want to say
something and I want people to
hear this because I don't want
to be, I don't want tone loss.
I think a lot of people hear
that and say easy for you
and you have it now, right?
And I'm empathetic to
that and I understand.
I implore those people
if they're curious,
if there's truth to
investigate the people
that knew me in
'93, '94, '95, '97, '99,
2001, 2003 I've
always been this happy.
It's always been this great
because I get to play the game,
you know?
See ya. Good day.
Wine Library.
Just grinding,
while you're sleeping.
How'd it go?
- [Woman 3] Amazing.
That was so sick.
- I listen to you every day
but today I teared up.
Four people have already tweeted
you should run for president.
Am I getting emails like crazy?
It was really good.
- [Woman 4] Hello.
- Did you like it?
- Oh, I loved it.
- What's up Facebook?
Cats.
- GaryVee.